but just first i thought i'd get your
reaction to what ninja ali said in that
interview there about afghanistan um the
uk and the us just cut and run she said
i speak as a former child refugee and as
a feminist and activist but i think that
both the uk and the us were actually
terrible in the way they handled
afghanistan i mean you obviously visited
the countries when you're a foreign
secretary do you think we cut and run
i i can understand that that is her view
um
i don't think anybody would argue that
the exit from afghanistan was handled
well
um there seemed to be a lot of questions
and there are a number of inquiries
going on
um into exactly what happened and why it
happened like that um but it does feel
very much as if not enough thought was
given
either to how the
um leaving of afghanistan would be
handled or indeed
as to how we can do more to to help and
safeguard what we're left behind
yes it's important and not to take our
eye off afghanistan while of course the
situation in ukraine remains what it is
as well um president biden yesterday
sounded an awful lot like he was calling
for regime change in russia when he said
that putin cannot remain in power
was he right to say what he did
i rather like what we've seen in joe
biden i know that he gets a lot of
criticism but he strikes me as being
somebody who has strong feelings and is
inclined to then just voice them
um
and you know
maybe we don't get quite enough of that
um sincerity and and
reaction sometimes from people in our
political world uh i'm sure that
his staff and the people around him are
right to say america's not calling for
regime change
but equally i think many people will
sympathize with the sentiments
that led him to say what he did
do you think that's something that
you've seen change in politics then in
the years you've been there people
speaking a little bit less directly i
suppose
i'm not sure it's changed i just think
that joe biden is is
more than most of us
a man who has
strong feelings and emotions and is
inclined to
say what he feels
it's difficult isn't it to for the west
to try and work out the right reaction
to the war in ukraine you see these
horrific war crimes being
committed but of course there is
concerns uh from the west about what
escalation would mean and the
consequences of that escalation
do you think that the uk and it's got it
just about right in the sanctions that
it's imposed supplying defensive weapons
but of course stopping short of
further escalation i suppose
i think it's a very difficult balance to
strike we are right of course to do
everything we can to support ukraine but
sometimes
i hear people um saying oh you know
we're not doing enough and that that may
be right maybe there's more we can do
but um
as if
uh okay let's send troops in and i kind
of think
are you really advocating a war between
nato and russia
because the idea that that would be
better
uh i i do find quite worrying
it's horrendous the situation in ukraine
and we have to do everything we can to
help
but to be drawn into a pan-european war
i don't think anybody would thank us
we heard from a ukrainian mp earlier on
the program and she said that
she felt like people have been
half-blind to what has been happening
with russia and ukraine in previous
years
do you think the west has previously
taken its eye off the ball with vladimir
putin and russia
i think there's been a perfectly natural
um
wish on everybody's part i mean the
whole gorbachev thing turned people's
approach towards russia
and people hoped that russia would more
and more come into the sort of
what you might call the mainstream of of
political life relationships between
countries and so on
but i'm i'm very mindful at any time
this past oh i don't know 10 20 years
if you talk to people in eastern europe
or rather perhaps if you listened to
people in eastern europe who had
experience of being under russian rule
they never had
um this sanguine approach they were
always
worried suspicious looking over their
shoulder saying you know russia hasn't
really changed you know
um
there are people in the baltic states
who will not be remotely surprised i
suspect what has happened in ukraine and
who do see themselves if russia got its
way as being next in line and in that
sense i think there's been something of
a of a divide
where
the rest of us who haven't had that
experience
have been inclined to want to see the
best and and hope for things to change
for the better in russia but people
who've lived under russia rule have
always been much more wary and i'm
afraid it now seems to me that we should
have listened more to them at the time
and as you say i think listening is
perhaps the key word isn't it rather
than talking as you said
now you've announced that you're going
to be retiring as a member of parliament
you were 40 years at the mp for derby
south the first female foreign secretary
are there any specific memories that
you're always going to keep from your
time in the house of commons
oh lots
too too many um to go into i think one
of the things that i would say though is
when i was first elected
this is a gross shorthand but roughly
speaking if somebody said there was a
photocall for all women mps you only had
to look round and you had
an idea whether we were all there or not
um
now i mean you know um it's it's not
remotely like that and indeed there was
a turning point when we used to have a
special section in the members cloakroom
just for the ladies
and i think it was after the 87 general
election that i came back and my peg had
moved i was like
oh well there are so many of you ladies
now that we've had to make it
alphabetical so
there are lots and lots of um
different memories most of them good
most of them good is that i think that
is that's nice i love the fact that they
had to make it alphabetical after that
election you're also of course labour's
first female leader when you appointed
acting leader in 1997
you've said since um that you know the
reason the party's never elected a
elected or female leader is because it
was just never was the right person at
the right time
but you know come on the labour party
was founded in 1900 you really think
it's never been the right time for a
female leader
i just think what people don't realize
who aren't practitioners in politics is
how much luck there is in politics
i mean
let's take the classic example margaret
thatcher margaret thatcher would never
have been the leader of the conservative
party if ted heath hadn't really really
offended so many people and upset them
so much they were prepared to have
anybody as long as it wasn't ted heath
and she got the credit for being willing
to stand against him if one of the men
had stood against him
then she wouldn't have been the leader
of the party there's a huge amount of
luck
and personally by the way my view is the
first woman prime minister should have
been barbara castle she would have been
an absolute star
um but it was never
quite the right time and so on so
and let's just say gen this happens at
every level a local council level
parliamentary selections and so on there
is an enormous amount of luck in
politics and the luck hasn't worked out
so far for one of our female colleagues
it will
just finally is there anything that
you're particularly looking forward to
doing more of in your retirement i mean
i know you're a keen a caravanner i
think and people always remember these
sort of images of you on your caravan
holidays what are you looking forward to
doing more of
well we had to give up our caravan about
a year ago because of my husband's
health um
and i'm thinking about whether or not to
try and get a motor car around but
there's a space thing about it that's
that's all
um
but
uh
i haven't quite settled into what i
would do in retirement yet because i
hadn't envisaged it without him
so difficult and i'm going to leave you
there and i know that he was someone who
of course so many people were very fond
of seeing around parliament and i know
i've spoken to you previously about what
a wonderful man he was as well so you
know
my best wishes to you and thank you very
much for being on the show